So over the last 48 hours, we've had a stunning
contrast between the man who is currently
president of the United States and the man
that wants to be president of the United States.
And I'm talking, of course, of Donald Trump
and Joe Biden.
Donald Trump, as I've already told you, to
some degree, I sat in the White House at one
point in the basement bunker at another point.
He went down to Florida to give a speech about
Elon Musk's success with NASA in launching
the Falcon nine rocket with the Dragon spacecraft
to bring two astronauts to the space station.
And Donald Trump essentially spent the weekend
tweeting, attacking the motives of protesters
threatening to release vicious dogs against
protesters and generally escalating tensions.
Meanwhile, Joe Biden, who is four years Trump's
senior, went out and wearing a mask, talk
to actual protesters about what's going on,
why they are protesting and all of these relevant
issues in society today took pictures with
people while tweeting, conciliatory and understanding
things rather than threatening people with
releasing the hounds, essentially.
The contrast could not be more stark at this
point.
No national address from Trump meant to reduce
tensions and bring people together instead.
A weekend of tweets about vicious dogs and
ominous weapons.
And the Secret Service is going to go after
people tweets talking about we're going to
make T for a terrorist organization.
And then Trump being rushed on Friday to the
underground bunker used to protect presidents
during terrorist attacks.
Below the White House, even China goading
Trump.
Foreign Ministry spokesman Lesin Zhao urged
the United States to eliminate racial discrimination
and protect the lawful rights of minorities.
Who is Eugene?
Editor of the nationalist tabloid The Global
Times telling Donald Trump, Mr. President,
don't go hide behind the Secret Service.
Now, that's Trump.
Then you have Biden.
Biden, who you don't have to like.
You don't have to see is a progressive because
he's not.
Joe Biden went and met with protesters, tweeted
conciliatory messages.
You don't have to love Biden to understand
the difference between these two men.
You don't have to see Biden as a progressive
because, as I said, he's not to realize that
the world is laughing at us and we would be
better off if they stopped.
And replacing Donald Trump with Biden is the
option we have five months from now.
And I will be doing everything I can to make
sure that that replacement takes place.
Trump tweeting about releasing the hounds
on protesters.
Joe Biden tweeting, quote, We are a nation
in pain right now, but we must not allow this
pain to destroy us.
As president, I will help lead this conversation.
And more importantly, I will listen, just
as I did today, visiting the site of last
night's protest in Wilmington.
Biden put publishing a five minute video discussing
what we are seeing with police and George
Floyd in some detail, adding, quote, We are
a country with an open wound.
None of us can turn away.
None of us can be silent.
None of us any longer can hear those words.
I can't breathe and do nothing.
We must commit as a nation to pursue justice
with every ounce of our being.
And most importantly, maybe Joe Biden not
hanging out and about in a bunker or in his
basement in Delaware, but just going out and
talking to protesters.
Were showing some of that video now.
So listen.
Am I saying Joe Biden is the be all end all
on criminal justice reform?
Of course not.
Joe Biden sponsored the 1994 crime bill that
was so destructive.
Bernie Sanders also voted for it, by the way.
And there is no doubt that not enough was
done during Barack Obama's administration,
of which Biden was apart on criminal justice.
But this is comparing apples to bicycle's.
It's comparing apples to trash when it comes
to Biden and Trump and the leadership deficit
that we're experiencing right now.
It's a tragedy.
And the optics of Trump tweeting from a White
House bunker while Joe Biden is kneeling with
protesters.
This isn't good for Trump.
It shouldn't be good for Trump.
And Biden, of course, would not get everything
right as president.
But at least he would bring back something
that looks and feels like leadership and like
a man connected to what's happening in the
country, rather than a guy who will literally
sit in his basement tweeting agit trash.
As more and more violence is instigated by
virtue
of his every tweet,